mesdames et messieurs la maîtresse de
cérémonie du 70e festival de cannes
mademoiselle monica bellucci
[Musique]
signore e signori bonne assiette
ladies and gentlemen good yvelines
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir merci de
votre présence et merci des renouveler
votre amour pour le cinéma ici ce soir
le cinéma cet art qui a la faculté de
nous extraire de la réalité pour mieux
nous irait plongé cet aller-retour le
bouscule mais nous permet aussi les
lever nos consciences
on a parlé souvent de la violence de
certains films les fameux scandale à
cannes les cinémas s'inspire du réel et
quand on pense à tout ce qu'il se passe
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que rien
rien n'est plus violent que la réalité
le cinéma n'est fait qu'y jouer son rôle
de miroir dans lequel ce réflexe nos
zones d'ombré mais aussi des lumières et
grâce à lui on peut se comprendre au
mieux on peut même se pardonner et
pourquoi pas s'aimer et il pouvait c'est
comme s'il aime lee cinéma pouvait
presque guérir nos blessures et grâce au
festival de cannes des grands cinéastes
ont pu révéler leur talent et leur
rapport au monde et sont devenus notre
patrimoine culturel et par ordre
chronologique
juste quelques exemples fellini lui noël
scorsese et coppola tornatore kusturika
les niches 20 heures shangai et kempen
wong kar-wai tarantino kassovitz bénigne
les dardenne moratti année qu'est noël
loach malik audiard garonnais sorrentino
maïwenn dolan et tant d'autres ils se
sentent dixième anniversaire nous a
permis d'aller visiter sa grande
histoire
elle est aussi la nôtre et heureusement
qu'à 70 ans on est encore à une tout
jeune homme et qu'on a encore beaucoup à
apprendre
il est donc espérer qu'à l'avenir
beaucoup plus de réalisatrice prendront
la juste place
mon rôle des femmes
mon rôle des femmes et des maîtresses de
cérémonie mme oblige donc à vous
rappeler qu'il en dit prenez garde à ne
pas faire pleurer une femme parce que
dieu compte ses larmes mais un dieu si
quand une femme prépare un coup les
diables sassia son bureau et de prendre
des notes
mesdames et messieurs place au palmarès
[Applaudissements]